you're hearing these numbers rebecca
okay
you've got a full-time job your husband
from what i understand he's he's a
worker he's a smart guy
the number she's talking about six
figures a month as you're hearing this
are you saying
honey i mean
[Music]
no
absolutely not um
that would never
cross my mind and if i said that to my
husband he would say go take a walk go
take a lap you're
delusional
so no amount of money would make you
reconsider what you're doing no because
she has a point here it's not like she's
going out with other men or doing other
being infidelity you know or anything
like that it's with her husband like she
said to use her words we're doing
everything we typically would do the
only difference is we turn the camera
around turn it on well
to me
and this goes back to my faith too
right you are defiling the marital bed
and i know to you as a like to you
you're not a christian so
that's not a part of your value system
but for me that's essentially saying
look
our marital bed our relationship is now
out here for everyone to see
and
i'm yeah i'm not i would never do that
it's not something you would do not at
all ruslan i already know you're going
to say no so i'm not going to ask you
the exact same question
but what like i don't want to turn this
into like sinners and saints yeah but
it's almost like she's using religion as
like a no according to my religion can't
do that
that's totally cool yeah no but yeah
yeah you as a follower of christ what
would the
bible or christianity have to say about
what because again not cheating on her
husband all she's doing is turning on
a camera yeah yeah i um
i would
say
according to scripture
if you're a follower of jesus the
standard the expectation is that
intimacy is reserved for one man one
woman relation marriage covenant to a
marriage
um and so that is that's the line right
that's got that god designed this
amazing thing called sex that's
phenomenal it's incredible it's one of
the best blessings out there
and what we tend to do as people is we
tend to take things and kind of like
throw our own spin on it right we
pervert something that's intended to be
good
food is good what do we do we make
highly caloric dense compressed fried
food with as many calories and it tastes
great and it's yummy and it's fulfilling
but what happens if you just eat
processed fast food you're going to get
overweight you're not going to like the
results you get and so i think most
things that we're talking about are in
the category of this is a this is an
amazing gift from god food sex
alcohol what i fill in the blank and we
take them and we we we distort them we
pervert them from the original design
and so i think it's less about her you
and your husband i think it's who is the
demographic that's consuming this and is
it adding a net positive to human
flourishing
or is it reinforcing dysfunctional
behavior in a lot of men who are maybe
becoming more socially isolated i mean
i'm sure we're familiar with a lot of
the in-cell community now right and so
like is this causing a man who's
consuming this not just you but in
general right
is this causing them to
view women as image bearers of god is
this causing them to have a healthy
expectation of what sex is i have no
idea how
elaborate and advanced your guys's
videos are very educated right
and so like is this causing them to have
healthy expectations because as a kid
that grew up with a ton of sexual trauma
um
and then got addicted to porn i had
really distorted views of what sex was
supposed to be you're saying that you
did yeah i did
you too yeah so you both are christians
followers of jesus and you both admit
that you had porn addictions yes yeah
well as a kid i was sexually abused um
about the age of seven or eight and that
exposed me to to porn and so then as i
got the internet it was like oh this is
this is a jackpot
right so like i got a computer to like
start producing music and i did but then
it also opened me up i'm like start
producing right here
and so that that was a stronghold over
over my life that was an addiction for a
while and i carried some of that what do
you consider a porn addiction what does
that mean when you don't want to do
something but you do it anyway when i go
ah i feel convicted i know this doesn't
help this doesn't help high view women
this doesn't help how i uh view my own
sexuality this doesn't help anything
this this causes shame and i can't
control it i think when you can't
control something it's an addiction
right when you when you it controls you
it controls you and that's definitely
what it was and so then
getting married and and uh my wife was
you know she wasn't she didn't have a
bunch of sexual partners and so like
then taking that into marriage so
definitely so i'm speaking as someone as
on the other side of being freed from
this the majority of men i'm dealing
with this isn't causing a net positive
to their life this is this is this is
hurting them this is um inhibiting and i
guess the the the pros of of of of uh
only fans is that at least the creators
are in control yeah historically porn
has been really bad a lot of overlap
with human trafficking yeah uh really
toxic stuff so i think the only a
positive i would say is like well at
least the creators are in control at
least as far as i know this isn't
connected to sex trafficking where
there's pimps
that was a real thing 10 years ago so
but but i would just still i would ask
man the dude that's looking at this
stuff
is this causing him
to add a net positive to society is this
causing him to be or is this causing him
to insulate deeper to
grow more dysfunctional have more issues
with his mental health um and so that
that's how i would that's how i would
look at it on a macro scale and then i
think from the creation of said content
uh then you filter that out so it's less
about what you and your husband do in in
your guys home it's more like
does it distort and does it add a net
positive to society and i think it's
hard to justify it so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
sauscast click right here
[Music]